Everything so far has been fairly similar to things that you've already seen.
We have just produced different polynomial functions and rational functions
through combining functions in different ways. But, now I think we should do
something totally new. Way back when we first started talking about functions I
showed you a little visual. I think it looked like this. It was a function
machine that takes an input and spits out an output. For example, we could
write a function that relates the number of wiper sets that Grant has sold,
let's call it N, to the amount of money he makes in the end, his revenue, which
we'll find using the function R. So, for example, if people spend $15 on a
wiper set, Then R of N will equal 15N. We can see that this function machine is
taking in N as its input, and spitting out R of N or 15N as its output. Now, if
Grant is trying to increase his revenue, or increase R, then he obviously wants
to increase the number of wiper sets that he sells. So how does he do that?
Well, as we saw before, the number of wiper sets that he sells, N, is a
function of the amount of money that he spends on advertising, which I'll call
d. Both revenue and money spent on advertising are going to be measured in
dollars. So now we have that R is a function of N and N is a function of d. So
how are R and N and d all related to one another? We should be able to then
draw a function diagram that represents this relationship. Which one of these
diagrams do you think is correct? Don't worry at all if this seems tricky. This
is definitely pushing the boundaries of our understanding of functions.